Hello.
Hello, Tony.
Yes.
How are you?
It's Frank Defratus.
I'm good.
How are you, Frank?
Doing pretty good.
Thought I would give you a call and find out some information about this light meter that you've put together, and you sent an email to me about that, and thank you for sending that.
If we were to talk about that, what would be the most important information you'd want the listeners to know about?
The most important thing I want listeners to know is is that it's available.
Okay.
Uh and uh this is something that that I put together because I I thought there was a need for it.
Mm-hmm.
Um apparently there used to be a a meter that everybody liked called uh Science Mechanics SM3.
Yes, I have that one.
And um I think that one is out of print at this point.
Yeah.
So I think there's a uh an opportunity here to replace that meter with uh, you know, uh twenty-first century uh upgraded kind of version.
And uh I have been doing holograms in in my basement for about three years now, and uh um I basically started with your book with shoebox holography.
Oh, that's great.
And uh I've kind of graduated from laser diodes to uh higher powered uh uh helium neon lasers and have a small table and I've I've experimented with all of the different kinds of silver halide film that I can and plates that I can get a hold of.
And what turned out to be your favorite to work with so far?
Well, so far I'd have to say my favorite is uh B B.
Yeah.
Um it's definitely the most reliable and it's uh the highest performing one that I've found.
Um I I think that probably Ultimate can also be very good, but I've had a really strange problem with Ultimate in that I haven't been able to get any that isn't like totally fogged.
Um that's interesting.
I uh I have gotten several batches and it the the folks at Ultimate have been very, very supportive uh trying to trying to help me out.
I've had several batches from France.
I've had one batch from Canada and we thought maybe it was X rays, but um now we we're pretty sure that's not the case and I've tried everything that I can think of.
Um so we're still in the midst of sorting out what's going on there.
But I think that uh Ultimate probably can give the same kind of performance, you know, uh based on what I've been able to see um uh fr you know, aside from the fact that I'm dealing with this horrendous fogging problem.
Um, but I I I expect that it would be uh nearly as good or perhaps even better than B B as far as noise and contrast and so forth.
Um and it I suspect it's much more sensitive.
Uh the drawback on B B is that it's it's it's fairly uh lower sense or less sensitive, I guess you'd say.
Yeah.
Um than most everything else, so it it requires a uh longer exposure or or higher power.
Where are you getting your B V plates from lately?
I buy them from Vintech.
Okay.
Oh, okay.
Yeah.
Yeah, South Carolina.
Okay.
They're super to deal with.
Um you can place a web order and and the stuff shows up in uh just a few days.
Yeah.
Did they say about the Ultima?
They think it might be your processing regimens.
Well, um they provide uh the developer.
Oh, I see.
Okay.
Um so um we've we've tried everything we can possibly think of.
The the uh there's a there's still an outside possibility that it's something to do with my safe lighting.
Okay.
Uh and uh other than that uh I mean we've we've we've exhaustively eliminated every variable that we can think of so far.
Um which is it's very strange and and I completely believe that it works at in at some locations but it just doesn't seem to work in Andover.
I don't know what the Yeah it's uh hmm it sometimes one of those variables turns out to be the most surprising element.
Yes.
You know it could it do you use tap water?
Uh we we've tried different kinds of water typically I use bottled water yeah uh and I tried an experiment with uh bottled distilled water uh which I would have thought either one of those would be fine.
The thing is I all all of my regimen uh has worked okay for many other kinds of film.
Yeah.
Uh you know I've got some old Ag Fa, I've got um Slavic and uh I've tried even I've even gotten some Fuji.
So you know I've tried a lot of different kinds of film and most of them work the way they you would expect them to work.
That's interesting.
But now you have a light meter.
That's right.
I saw a picture of it.
It's very nice with the digital readout.
Uh huh.
What are the functions on there?
Uh essentially uh it it gives you four numbers at a time.
Okay.
That's as much information as I could squeeze on the display.
And the top two numbers are uh your reading in power for the object beam and the reference beams.
Okay.
And uh one of the bottom numbers is the total of the two beams, so that's just adding the power together.
And the other is uh typically a ratio.
I see.
And so you can set it up, you can place the sensor where your film is, and you can card off one beam and and measure the other.
Then you know, so for example you could cart off the reference beam and measure the object and punch the button in for that.
And then you can uh card off the object beam and measure the reference and at that point it'll give you a display of the ratios.
I see totals.
Yeah.
So if you're shooting for a particular ratio that you like um you can you can tune it in that way.
And it's all real time.
And the power readings have trending on them so that they have a little plus and minus sign that comes and goes depending on whether the reading is going up or going down.
Whether things are going up or down.
So I added that function in so that you can use it for uh adjusting optics.
Uh you can find the the center of the beam, you can just set it up and tune your spatial filter for a maximum output uh which is basically the optimum setting in most cases unless there's something funny with your optics.
Mm-hmm.
And it also can do optical density.
Oh okay yeah.
So in that case uh you can set it up so that it measures the uh basically the log of the ratio of the the two readings.
And so what you would do for that is you'd put the sensor in a little plastic bag and put it face up on the table, and you can develop your film and um put it in some stop bath or fixer or something so that you can turn the lights on, and then you can um basically measure the room light with nothing over the sensor, just the ambient light, and then you put your film over the sensor and measure the other reading, and it'll compute that uh the log of that ratio and tell you what your optical density is.
That's interesting.
I noticed that a lot of the instructions and the uh spec sheets that come with uh holographic films fail to mention anything about uh final densities at all.
Right.
In the olden days, back in the day of uh color separations and things like that and uh outputting, you know, film from like uh line of type machines, uh laser uh printers and things that uh you always went for a density.
Always put your film under a densitometer.
Right.
Yeah.
I think uh some people are you know get uh uh into the numerical accuracy of it.
Um some film manufacturers I think the Slavic webpage does have a a density versus exposure and curve.
Um but I think there's some experimentation also uh uh you know there's kind of a rule of thumb that I've observed over the three years that I've been paying attention, uh that transmission holograms want to be around one to two and reflection holograms want to be two or better.
Yeah.
Um so that's that's useful for that.
I mean a lot of people just develop by eye and a lot of processing schemes don't uh account for uh being able to make a density measurement before you bleach it.
Yeah, yeah.
Um but I think it might still be possible to do that if you if you had a for example, if you had a a light source which was not in the sensitive area of the film you're using.
Mm-hmm.
So if you're using red sensitive film, if you had a green LED as a light source, you could probably still go ahead and do a density reading on it even before it's uh bleached.
Yeah, yeah, and if if it's not your reading, you get back get it back into the developer.
Right.
Yeah.
And let me ask you this, is is is the uh L L E uh the L C D panel that's on your your light meter, is that backlit?
Yes it is.
Great.
Uh it has a a green backlight to it.
And um the uh the backlight um uh consumes a lot of a lot of power from the battery.
It that's the thing draws almost no power except for the backlight.
Yeah.
And so the thing has an automatic power down.
If you don't punch any buttons for five minutes, it shuts itself off.
Wow.
Uh and then if you just touch a button it comes back on again.
Well, you really thought of everything with this, didn't you?
I've I've had uh some experience um building things that involve uh a processor and three buttons.
Uh I build a number of of different products for different martic markets kind of on my own.
And so I have kind of a canned uh hardware approach using some of these microchip uh computers that are absolutely phenomenal.
There's as much processing power in in these single chips as there was on the first computer I learned on, which was a PDP eight back in nineteen sixty eight.
I think around nineteen seventy I was on maybe a machine one of them called Wangs.
Mm-hmm.
Yeah.
Had punch cards.
You punch punch out a program on a card and you put that in punch card into a little reader and then you go on to the little terminal and do your work.
Yeah.
Yeah, that was something.
Back in the days of punch cards and paper tape.
So you long way you go back quite a way too, huh?
Yeah I do.
Uh I uh I can remember first getting interested in lasers and holography from a uh probably a popular science magazine article about Eupatniax and Leith when they were when they made their first uh transmission hologram.
And uh then I uh did some holography in the early seventies when I was uh in high school.
Mm-hmm uh I got some information from Scientific American article and I made split uh split beam transmission holograms on my basement floor and I I still have some of them.
They're they're pretty amazing that they've lasted this long.
Yeah.
And then the the internet is an incredible thing because every once in a while, late at night I'll get bored with whatever I'm doing and I'll just type something random into a search engine and about three years ago I typed amateur holography into a search engine and that that was just the beginning of a brand new hobby for me.
I've been going uh pretty steadily ever since.
Well I really respect the fact that even though you did holograms back in the seventies when you first came on the program you said you've been involved for three years uh because there's nothing that drives me nuts as much as folks that did a couple holograms, you know, back in the seventies or eighties for a project or whatever, or maybe they worked on it for a year or whatever and then for twenty years haven't done anything and then they get back into the field and the next thing you know they're saying they've been involved with holography for twenty years.
Yeah.
That drives me crazy.
And it that's out there too.
But the internet is wonderful.
Folks from all over the world will hear your interview.
I don't know if it'll sell any light meters but uh they'll listen to the show.
But hopefully speaking of which do you have a standalone website that has information about this meter?
Because I can include that link.
I haven't uh gotten that sophisticated yet.
Um I posted it on the uh holography forum and if folks are interested in getting a look at it and reading about it uh I would direct them there.
Um just go to the holography forum and look at the for sale section and there's a uh a new product announcement in there.
Okay.
And um holography is basically a hobby to me and I I thought that I could make a contribution to holography by making this meter.
Uh it this isn't gonna be anything that's gonna support me in my old age.
I know I'm not gonna quit my day job.
Um and at the same time if if I'm gonna build a quality product and and I'm not gonna make a kit, I'm not gonna make it something that that won't work.
Yeah stay away from the kits.
Um really I need to charge a fair price for it.
Yeah.
Um so so that's that's where it's priced and and that's where it's intended to be.
And what is the price?
Uh 1795.
US dollars.
Yeah.
Okay.
And that includes uh a sensor.
And I use a a solar cell for a sensor.
Mm-hmm.
And um I've chosen that sensor because I've found that it's inexpensive.
Uh it's a l nice large area, uh, so that you can integrate over a an area of the uh of the plate.
Uh it's very thin, so you can position it uh in the plane of the of the film readily, you know, it's not uh bulky.
Um and it also it's it has a very low reflectivity.
Uh a very dull surface, which means you don't have to concern yourself about uh the several percent that might be reflecting off the front, say from a typical sensor that has a a uh glossy shiny face to it.
Yeah.
And that actually happens when you put a holographic plate into the plate holder as well.
You're you're still losing a certain percentage off of that first surface that uh you didn't capture when you were doing the uh light reading.
Right.
Yeah.
Um the uh the meter can be calibrated for different wavelengths and also for different sensors.
If someone has an application um for a a a different type of sensor or a different wavelength, uh then a calibration I can just come up with a calibration for it and put it in.
And uh it's all reprogrammable.
So if I come up with a new idea or new feature, or if someone buys a meter and then later on wants to, you know, they go from red to green, uh it can be reprogrammed.
Okay.
Send it back and uh hopefully it'll get better, you know, as people come up with new ideas and things that I can do with it.
Okay, so basically it is for whether you're either using the meter in the red part of the spectrum or the green part of the spectrum.
Right.
Out of the box.
And and the power range?
Um well the power range is somewhat affected by the sensor.
Uh and the the power range that that I'm able to really feel confident with is up to about thirty-five milliwatts.
Okay.
Because that's that's the most powerful laser I have here.
Um electrically speaking, it reads from uh one microwatt to one watt.
Um but you know, obviously when you get into the higher power levels, you may have to do some calibrating for the sensor.
Mm-hmm.
I'd get one myself, but I I work by eye now.
Like the old photographers would do back in the early days of photography.
I don't I I rarely even do uh readings anymore myself.
I think after you you make so many holograms for so many years, you can pretty much just look at a setup.
And y you're already in the ballpark, your your mind already knows where you need to be.
But for but for someone that's just starting out, it's uh it it's of utmost importance.
Because you're training your mind at that point.
That's right.
And the mind remembers over time.
It may not remember just after doing it for a week, but if you're doing it you're doing it day after day, week after week and year after year, eventually you just look at something and you can pretty much tell where you're going to be with it.
I agree with that, and and I think one thing that makes that whole process easier is if you can standardize.
Um so for example, um I just I just do red and I stay with a four by five uh inch format.
Mm-hmm.
And my table geometries are are fairly pretty stable.
Um they're usually one of two choices depending on whether I'm making H1s or H2 copies.
And um so with all of that, you're right, you you do develop a a feeling or an intuition for uh what what works.
Um but still if uh if you're experimenting or you're going a little bit outside your envelope, maybe with a different color or different laser or uh sometimes the subject matter too can be a little tricky or a different film like uh uh I mean most of the silver films are are fairly similar, but there is some variation.
I I definitely think the ultimate's more sensitive and the BB is less sensitive.
And if you're using a brand new film, you probably want to start where the manufacturer uh recommends.
Yes.
It's a good starting point, and uh a meter can help you make sure you're starting there and help you eliminate some of the variables right out of the box.
Yeah, yeah.
Have you worked on any larger format films or plates yet, like eight by ten and up?
No, I haven't.
Uh as I said, I've I've kind of specialized.
Um I have a uh a two by two table that I've built.
Um it's a hex can table.
Oh, okay.
So it's literally um soda cans uh between two skins of steel.
That was John Clayer that started that.
Yeah, I think it might have been him.
Yeah.
But but there are a lot of different people who've who've who've uh investigated it.
And uh you know, I built one.
I uh uh another interesting thing about my approach is that um I don't have a lot of room, even though I have a reasonably sized house, um I have a lot of other hobbies going on.
I'm into amateur radio model rocketry um and uh so space is a premium and I I didn't have a room that I could dedicate as a dark room.
So I've taken over uh actually my wife ended up uh convincing me to to remodel the downstairs bathroom so that it can be used both for chemistry and for regular downstairs bathroom function.
You've been bitten by the bug so um one of the things that I developed is a technique where most of my my um processes can be carried out in room light.
Um so I use um five by seven Graphlex film holders as my film holder.
Okay.
And I rebuild 'em so that you can put a a piece of four by five film or a sandwich between glass or you can put a a glass plate in them and they'll it'll be mounted stably and that was a a trick in itself.
Um and then you can put the slides on this thing and you can carry it around the house.
Wow.
And then my table is enclosed uh in uh foam core.
It's uh about a three foot cube around this two foot table and on one side there's a port where I've cut out a square and I've made uh what looks like uh a Graphlex camera entry.
Okay.
It's uh insulated from light and vibration by several layers of black trash bag plastic.
And you can position everything you want inside the box and put the plate holder in and close up the box and then pull a dark slides out and then you can make an exposure that way.
Well do you have any pictures anywhere of this?
Because this is sounding awful familiar to me.
Like I've seen some pictures of of your studio or something.
I think I've put some pictures like this uh up on um uh Michael Harrison's website if you've been kind enough to host some space for me.
Yeah.
Because it all sounds very familiar like I've seen it.
Uh so I may have described some of it and put up some pictures.
Yeah, because I've never been there.
We've never met, right?
No.
No we've never met.
Nope.
Alright, anything you want to add, Tony?
We're coming up well actually over twenty minutes now.
I like to keep it short just so that the file sizes don't get too big because the audio files.
Some people are still on dial up modems and that's fine, but what I try to do is to make everybody happy.
So I try to keep the file sizes as small as possible because they're downloading on you know dial up modems and things still.
Anything you'd like to add before we close it out.
Uh I think we've I'm just uh kind of looking at a cheat sheet here to see if we've covered everything um uh basically it's uh it's an accurate light meter um it gives you some computations that uh help you out.
It has real time readings uh that you can use if you're making adjustments or if you're trying to set beam ratios um and uh runs on a battery and simple to use and uh and affordable and affordable yes.
So I'm I'm hoping that some some folks will be uh interested in it and uh you know I I'm just trying to uh make whatever kind of a contribution I can to the hobby.
Yeah.
Um and and really that's my point of view on it.
Uh I I I'm not like many people who sort of think that holography is gonna be the next big thing.
Well, good for you because you're in for a big surprise.
Yeah, I know.
I'm drawing a blank, so just hold on with me here for a second.
Um how can someone get in touch with you?
Um Do you want to give your phone number?
Do you want me to put your phone number on the on the Holotalk website uh page when people listen to the show or what do you want them to do?
Probably the best thing would be to um give out uh the email address.
Okay.
I think that would be and I'll place a link to that also so that people can just click on that and send you an email.
Yeah.
That would be that would be the best thing.
Do you have a PayPal account where people can pay you online or just check money order thing?
Uh I do have a PayPal account.
Okay.
Uh at the moment I can only accept uh uh payment from a checking account.
I can't payment from a credit card because I'm just uh I'm just really a user and not a seller.
I see.
Well you can let everybody you can work that out with everyone else when they contact you.
I can't take credit cards.
I can't accept credit cards.
Oh, okay.
Um I I I have access to a merchant account where I can run those through.
Okay.
So wanna give them the email address?
Sure.
Uh it's B A R O C K T E E R at A O L dot com.
Okay.
Oh, okay.
And that's from one of my other hobbies that I resurrected by typing something into the internet late at night.
Hmm.
Yeah, I I did some little model rocketing when I was a kid.
It was a lot of fun.
Well uh like holography, the model rocketry area has grown up as well.
And when you were a kid you probably thought a C or a D was a big engine.
Yeah.
And nowadays uh the the um model rocketry can go as high as M.
Wow.
And each letter is a doubling, it's uh a doubling of the amount of power.
Isn't that something?
I know some people launch cameras and everything on, you know.
Cameras, video, um small children.
Pets well, you're not supposed to launch anything with a backphone.
That's the Oh, is that what it is?
Isn't that something, huh?
Well, I'll have to look I no, I'm not going to look that up.
I'm not going to look that up.
That's it.
I've got too many things going on now.
That's right.
When I turned fifty, I chose there were a few things that I was going to continue to do, and I was dropping everything else, and I chose holography.
Getting back involved with music and composing again, which I've started to do.
I put a recording studio in.
And uh fitness, you know, cycling, I'm just boxing and things of that nature that I've been doing for years.
Well that's a great one.
That's it.
That is it.
Nothing else and nothing new.
This is gonna take me out for the rest of my life, and I don't I'm not gonna put model rocketry into a search engine.
That was a lot of fun though.
I have seen some videos of people who have had the small uh USB type cameras or whatever it was that they had on the nose of the rocket, and they'd launched that up into the neighborhoods and stuff, and it was like I've gotta do this.
But I'm gonna stay away from it.
Alright, Tony.
It was really nice talking to you.
Well, thank you very much for calling.
I hope we get a chance to meet sometime.
Yeah.
We're not too far apart from one another.
No.
And uh maybe one of these days they'll they'll have some kind of a get together uh in the northeast.
I know that they they've been trying to have one.
I tried to have one in Georgia, but it kind of fizzled out.
Yeah.
But uh if they had one in the northeast, I think we would we would get together.
Well, I get up there sometimes around Cape Cod, Martha's Vineyard uh area.
I don't know how far that is from you from where you are.
Well, um But if I ever find myself coming up there again, probably won't be this summer.
I'm only about a two-hour drive from the Cape.
Okay.
Um probably actually you know, about an hour and a half from the bridges.
Infamous bridges.
I st I usually stay in a town called Falmouth.
Uh-huh.
Yeah.
So that's only about an hour and a half from me here.
Yeah, and then we take the boat over.
All right, Tony.
All right, Frank.
Have a good rest of the night, and uh at some point I'll get this all.
I don't think we need to do too much I don't do too much editing on it.
If I stumble over something, I usually leave it in, but if someone else stumbles, I'd take it out for them if they want to.
But you did a wonderful job.
You were prepared, you knew what you wanted to say, and you got it across comprehensively, and uh I think we'd be ready to go with it.
Great.
Well, thank you very much for the opportunity.
Sure.
Howdyos, amigo.
All right, thanks, Frank.
Talk to you later.
Bye.